so konnte bekomme ich den kopf von
kontrast und jetzt seht ihr wie ich
unter der maske aussieht so sehe ich
unter der maske
hey leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft sie wieder am
dienstag und zwar habe ich wieder ein
perfekt vorbereitet die ich euch heute
vorstellen möchte allerdings sind defekt
diesmal relativ kurz allerdings trotzdem
sehr lehrreich was euch auf jeden fall
auf eurer reise weiterhin durch die
minecraft abenteuer bild sehr viel
weiterbringen wird und zwar würde ich
sagen fangen an ihre gesammelten ersten
effekt und zwar kommt effekt vom see
wieder hat mir dann meine konkret kommen
geschrieben da könnt ihr mit dem effekt
sind schreiben und er meinte dass kleine
zombies bei tag nicht verbrennen als
wenn ich jetzt hier normalen zombie
marston würde so der wirt direkt
anfangen zu brennen daher tag ist blabla
essen ist ein [ __ ]
aber diese kleinen baby zum ist ich weiß
nicht ob es ein bug ist oder ob es
einfach gewollt ist die kleinen brennen
halten nicht und außerdem wenn dieser
zombie einen helm auf hätte würde auch
nicht brennen das wirkt dann wie so
einen sonnenschutzfaktor wie sonne käppi
halt irgendwie aber nach einer gewissen
zeit wird er halt dadurch halt
verbrennen und dementsprechend dann
sterben bei den kleinen ist dies
allerdings nicht der fall also die
kleinen sind feuer geschützt uhr so
freunde der zweite fake kommt von maxi
king 98 mit xx davor und dahinter ich
weiß nicht wie man das macht maxi king
kannst wenn man die kommentare schreiben
das video gerade an guckst aber es ist
ein ganz interessanter fake der immer
noch mehr zugesendet als ich denke von
maxi king werde ich auch noch dann im
dritten weg benutzen
aber es egal und zwar geht es also
weekend serie laufen bei switch ein
bisschen ich kann euch jetzt auch noch
mal eine frohe ich hab jetzt ich hab die
ketten haube auf welche ahnung was
getestet habe ich rutsche ich immer so
ein bisschen wenn ich ganz normal gehe
ich rutsche immer so ein bisschen das
kann dann schon mal dazu führen dass
dann einfach so laufen dann rutsche ich
hier vom blog runter zackig einfach
unten
allerdings wenn ich über die kante des
blockes laufe rutsche ich kein bisschen
warte ich mal ganz günstige cantet hin
hier so genau ich rutsche kein bisschen
ich kann mir einfach so vor laufen und
auch hier wieder zurück dann ihr sprich
rutschen nicht also wenn nicht direkt
auf der kante lauf und quasi mein mann
mein bein
rechtes bein mehr auf der rechten seite
ist also wenn ich so bin warte wenn
nicht so gut funktioniert dass halt
nicht wenn ich dann halt wieder im
rutschen im bereich bin ich allerdings
so will sollte es funktionieren genau so
funktioniert es welche zulauf für
funktioniert und ich werde nicht
rutschen wenn ich auf der kante eines
blogs laufe wenn ich allerdings in der
mitte laufe dann rutschig ein weiterer
cool effect auch von maxi king ist ich
glaube ich stelle den sold als fake
berater suche bei mir einfiel zuhause
nennen spaß also der etwa auf jeden fall
echt cool effect zugesendet ist wenn ich
ja ganz normal in die kiste habe und
hier dann irgendwie ein blog darüber hab
da kann jetzt noch mal dass hier über
all das hier so drüber packen kann ich
die kiste nicht öffnen egal ob ich im
game und 1 oder game 0 oder game o2 bin
das ist vollkommen egal allerdings wenn
ich hier verschiedene laub sorten
darüber hab also ich habe hier
beispielsweise eichenlaub fichten tannen
fichtennadeln birken laub und tropen
laub ich kann die kisten da immer noch
öffnen weil dieses laub nicht so richtig
als block erkannt weil ich dadurch
gucken kann mehr oder weniger und was
ich jetzt auch noch mal ganz kurz testen
könnte was ich mich mal grad zur frage
was ist denn wenn ich dann zaun drüber
paket per vierten dan und ok es auch
öffnen wahrscheinlich nur immer wenn du
denn diese animation nicht so komplett
voll ist also bei einem 10 15 ist das ja
interessant und jetzt fängt es an zu
regnen
so meine lieben freunde kommen wir zum
fun fact uns war es dieser effekt sehr
sehr geil und ich denke dass er sich
auch weiterhelfen wird in dass es auch
schon oft irgendwo gegoogelt wurde wie
das ganze denn funktioniert und zwar wie
kann ich meinen eigenen kopf als
woanders gibt es überhaupt hier kann ich
mir das hier überhaupt war der moment
moment ich kann mir doch irgendwie das
ist doch ganz ist muss auch wirklich
dass ich mir irgendwie das kann damit
das ist auch einfach hier das muss doch
irgendwie machbar sein da hier genau
hier gibt es ja diese köpfe die man sich
einfach in wohin stellen kann
wie kann man denn conny sag doch wie
kann ich dann meinen eigenen kopf da
drinnen haben also das geht ganz einfach
mit diesem kommentar also mit diesem in
dieser sache die mit dem chat eingeben
397 ist die block nummer 13 wofür das
genau steht also eins ist die anzahl und
drei weise nicht und dann skala also
kopf besitzer kontrakte oder muss das
andere zählt sie auch noch groß machen
so kontraste bekomme ich hier den kopf
von kontrast und jetzt seht ihr wie ich
unter der macht
so sehe ich unter der maske aus das ist
so sehe ich so aus und so wie dieser
blog da ist so sehe ich unter der maske
auf das ist einfach nur eine
ich bin ein bandit also ich kann hier
natürlich auch andere sachen eingehen
ich kann natürlich auch eingeben und
gespielt weil ich jetzt den kopf von
und/oder heißt überhaupt gespielt hast
gespielt doch da ist also wahrscheinlich
bisschen zum laden oder den adress zum
beispiel dna in minecraft und dann kann
ich mich alle möglichen töpfe holen
goma hd kann ja eingeben d
so hätte dann habe ich alle möglichen
töpfe in minecraft meiner sie ein
bisschen komisch aus welcher eine maske
auf habe hier den mann machte aber das
ist der fun fact weil ihr könnt mit
diesem kommentar halt einfach euren
eigenen kopf und in eure eigene welt
reinsetzen und jetzt wisst ihr wie ich
unter meiner maske aussehe und ich würde
sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat und ihr
wieder was dazugelernt habe dann könnte
er van daumen hoch da lassen das zeigt
mir halt wie gesagt lasst euch diese
serie weiterhin gefällt ihr könnt mir
weiterhin ein konkreter gmail.com facts
schreiben und ich würde sagen
kommentiert ganz viel ob wir das gewusst
hat oder ich keine ahnung mir fehlt die
stimme